pose de faire un petit saut en arrière
enfin un petit façon parler de 50 ans
très exactement où presque exactement
puisque le dimanche 27 avril le palais
de l'elysée publiait ce communiqué du
général de gaulle qui était président de
la république à l'époque je cesse
d'exercer 1969 donc je cesse d'exercer
mes fonctions de président de la
république
cette décision prend effet aujourd'hui à
midi il y avait eu un référendum
organisé le jour même qui avait été
perdu par le général de gaulle sur un
sujet d'organisation des pouvoirs
publics un peu compliqué sur lequel on
reviendra pas mais est ce que c'est ce
qui d'ailleurs peut-être ce qui peut
être intéressant premier là dedans
guillaume bernard c'est que voilà un
chef de l'état qui utilisait le
référendum qui n'en avaient pas peur ben
non c'est un chef de l'état qui assume
ses responsabilités qui est d'une
certaine manière je dirais à la fois une
relation directe aux français et qui
d'une mais qui je dirais respecte
la parole des français qui se dit que
pour avoir une légitimité il faut non
seulement avoir la légitimité d'origine
celle qui a conduit à ce que vous
arriviez au pouvoir la procédure qui
conduit l'accession au pouvoir mais en
outre une légitimité d'exercice c'est à
dire le fait de que l'on exerce le
pouvoir dans une certaine finalité que
sa réalise le bien commun que ce soit
compris qu'une relation de confiance
donc de ce point de vue là
incontestablement de gaulle avait une
stature de chef de l'état que l'on peut
évidemment regretté alors de gaulle
après évidemment le goal le gaullisme
c'est de gaulle en 40 c'est de gaulle
avec en 47 le rpf c'est de gaulle ont 60
62 enfin 58 le 13 mai les suit 60 62 bon
pour ma part j'avoue que mon de gaulle
préféré c'est pas celui de 60 plutôt du
côté de georges bidault qui prend le
maquis ou août ou de ou de michel debré
qui quitte matignon pour ne pas avoir à
appliquer les accords d'evian
mais en revanche moi mon de gaulle à moi
c'est le discours de bayeux
parce que c'est le discours de bayeux
c'est le fait qu'il impose
je dirais une certaine vision de la brit
girl appareils pas prêtes à la fin de la
deuxième guerre mondiale où charles de
gaulle trace le portrait de ce qui va
être la constitution de la 7ème
république
sauf que tu es adrien matou que si
aujourd'hui nos responsables politiques
ont si peur du référendum
c'est parce que le général de gaulle l'a
un peu détournée de son objet et violent
faisant une affaire personnelle
oui mais en fait j'ai l'impression que
quand par le général de gaulle on
regrette aussi une époque en fait
puisque regard d'une époque il y avait
une croissance économique très forte un
showmatch quasiment inexistant ou
comment penser aux progrès techniques on
n'avait pas peur d'une élimination mais
c'était vraiment un signe de progrès et
d'amélioration des conditions de vie et
où le chef de l'état était un héros de
guerre quelqu'un qui avait sauvé la
france dans les années 40 donc c'est
c'est compliqué de dire voilà on est
évidemment cros regrette de gaulle parce
que c'est aussi un arraché d'état qu'ils
aient la politique de la france ne se
fait pas à la corbeille
je sais pas s'il ya un seul le travail
c'est la course et élaborer ce qu'on
appelle la bourse avait pas si un seul
de ses successeurs qui pourrait dire ça
aujourd'hui c'est voilà c'est en fait
c'est vraiment une autre époque pour le
coup on comprend qu'on le regrette c'est
une époque qui était céline beaucoup
plus d'optimisme qu'aujourd'hui alors
est ce que c'est une époque révolue
peut-être pour nourrir le débat je
propose d'écouter le point de vue d'eric
zemmour lui considère au contraire que
de gaulle est très moderne parce que
c'est peut-être le père des populistes
vous savez le général de gaulle avait
une formule il disait d'abord la france
ensuite l'état puis le droit là on a
inversé la proposition gaullienne
aujourd'hui on a ce que les français
appelait jadis le gouvernement des juges
donc ça et qu'est ce que disent les
représentants de la démocratie il
libéral les femmes meurent banner et
autres polonais etc
c'est le peuple qui décide ce n'est pas
le juge ce ne sont pas les principes
c'est la majorité et non les minorités
qui s'appuie sur le pouvoir de ce juge
pour gouverner et pour tyranniser la
majorité ces deux conceptions de la
démocratie aujourd'hui le général de
gaulle serait traité de nationalistes de
populiste je m'étais un peu osé ce point
de vue mais est ce que ça vous paraît
intéressant moi ce que j'aime dans
l'histoire de la france je rappelle qu
emmanuel macron a dit hier qu'il voulait
en fait trouvé l'art d'être français et
à ce moment là je me suis dit tiens là
il ya un élément de rassemblement
d'ailleurs l'art d'être française pas
trop ce que ça veut dire mais il ya
quelque chose d'énorme non mais il ya
quelque chose de l'alchimie comme si on
savait ce que veut dire la france et je
suis persuadé que chacun d'entre nous si
on l'interrogeait dirait quelque chose
de différent donc au moins de gaulle
avait la capacité ont dix ans la france
d'imaginer de nous fédérer et je pense
qu'elle maniait mac ont essayé avec
l'art d'être français de nous montrer
que nous avions en commun une forme de
dignité mais là quand tu disais quand de
gaulle disait le peuple avant les juges
est ce que ça en fin la question d'eric
zemmour c'est que lui confond toujours
le droit et les juges
enfin vous savez le droit c'est les
avocats le droit c'est une manière de
défendre les faibles les victimes
donc moi je n'aurais je ne résout pas la
question du droit à celle des jus
tout puissant dont parlait avec zemmour
de manière obsessionnelle depuis
maintenant 25 ans donc ce qui vise quand
même c'est avant tout la question que
l'état de droit est instrumentalisée à
des fins politiques pour des choix
politiques et pas uniquement pour
préserver les libertés publiques
si c'est que du temps du général de
gaulle sans doute la question de l'état
était aussi plus structurée
qu'aujourd'hui et ça rejoint ce que je
disais tout à l'heure sur le fait qu'il
faut inventer une pensée de l'état dans
une mondialisation ou au fond ce qu'on
vit tout à fait ce que disait guillaume
on vit une espèce de crise identitaire
terrible parce qu'on ne sait plus où est
la structuration de ce que c'est qu'être
français être européen être citoyen du
monde il faut articuler tout ça donc on
peut le faire avec le droit mais ça ne
suffira pas il faut évidemment le faire
aussi avec de la culture du débat de la
contradiction se dire qu'on n'est pas
d'accord entre nous pas seulement vivent
dans des univers parallèles et en ce
sens on n'est plus du tout à l'époque du
général de gaulle moi j'ai pas vécu du
tout
enfin j'étais né mais j'ai pas vécu le
truc de vivre le général de gaulle comme
mon président je dire je n'avais pas du
tout de majorité politique
donc c'est difficile d'en parler
seulement des livres d'histoire voyez
mais ce qu'on a raconté c'est quand même
que c'était un moment très autoritaire
donc moi je suis pas sûr que j'aurais
aimé vu dans les années 60 avec le
général de gaulle est compressé on en
revient à remédier à cette thèse de ces
mots parce qu'effectivement la les
médias étaient assez contrôlé le conseil
constitutionnel était été tenues entre
guillemets verrouiller un petit peu
comme ce que font ces démocraties
libérales
d'abord c'est une autre époque le
général de gaulle à une autre histoire
c'est quand même un homme qui né au 19e
siècle qui a un rapport à l'histoire qui
est un rapport tragique qui n'a pas là
quand même conception du pouvoir qui
exercent l'autorité pleinement et qui ne
se posent pas la question de savoir si
il va l'exercer admis et puis surtout il
ya alors je suis d'accord avec ce que
vous dites il plusieurs de gaulle il ya
eu plusieurs de gaulle mais il ya quand
même ça il ya quelque chose qui est
fondamental c'est de gaulle il avait une
phrase qui rejoint en fait ce que dit
d'une certaine manière et morizet la
démocratie est indissociable de la
souveraineté nationale
c'était le fond philosophique du général
de gaulle pour lui ne pouviez pas avoir
de démocratie si un moment donné la
parole du peuple et est respecté et
c'est ce qui est intéressant finalement
allées de gaulle c'est sa relation avec
les institutions et notamment avec les
institutions de la vème république qui
l'a créé parce que ils les appliquer
pleinement quasiment dans sa chair c'est
à dire qu'à un moment donné il mettait
son destin en jeu plus aucun président
de la république n'a fait ça depuis il
est le seul à avoir d'ailleurs il a
quitté deux fois le pouvoir parce qu'il
quitte le pouvoir en 46 il faut aussi ne
jamais l'oublier parce qu'il est en
désaccord finalement avec les liait
forces politiques qui sont revenus après
à la libération considérant que le
système institutionnel qu'on va proposer
à la france était système institutionnel
qui ne garantira pas la réforme de
l'état et la stabilité des institutions
donc il quitte et il le fait également
en 1969 or aujourd'hui le problème c'est
que je reviens avec macron et c'est vrai
pour d'autres présidents la république
c'est que finalement ils utilisent le
confort des institutions de la vème
république mais sans aller jusqu'au bout
de la logique de ces institutions et ce
sont des institutions les institutions
de la vème république
fondamentalement héroïque qui me demande
finalement un chef qui a qui va jusqu'au
bout finalement de sa logique politique
alors
quand même pas à résoudre la question
institutionnelle au fait de respecter un
référendum
aujourd'hui la question du référendum et
la question du référendum se pose
différemment dans un monde ultra
complexe très ouvert et il faut mieux
informer les citoyens et là c'était un
quitte ou double ce référendum
aujourd'hui on est plus dans les mêmes
enjeux on est d'accord mais c'est la
question qui se pose est ce que les
institutions de la vème république
aujourd'hui sont adaptés à la société
dans laquelle j'étais je vous rappelle
la fois cette formule gaullienne cité
par zemmour d'abord la france ensuite
l'état puis le droit moi je suis assez
souvent d'accord avec eric zemmour donc
évidemment ça ne vous étonnera pas que
que je ne l'approuvent
mais pour revenir un instant au discours
de bayeux vraiment un instant c'est
promis qu'on est loin du
on est d'accord non parce que vous allez
voir c'est le coeur à l'aide car le à
46,46 juin 46 il ya eu le référendum qui
a rejeté le projet communiste de
constitution et il prend position pour
au moment il va y avoir un 2e des bases
de siam a scandé voilà en 35 secondes 1
les français eux sont effervescents il
faut donc des institutions qui les
canalise et notamment je virais un
esprit monarchique premiers éléments et
vous comprenez bien que c'est quelque
chose qui me satisfait 2e et les 2 est
deuxième élément il faut à tout prix des
institutions qui met sous cloche les
intérêts partisans
les partis qui ont un esprit mortifère
malheureusement je crains que la
révision de 62 avec l'élection du
président de la république au suffrage
universel direct mais évidemment
redonner tout pouvoir au parti politique
mais je dirais le fait de détester les
partis politiques comme le faisait de
gaulle en 46 ça me conviendrait bien le
droit de vote aux femmes de gaulle ça
sert à ça c'est un trésor absolument
alors nos internautes sont 61%
c'est pas non plus écrasants a regretté
le général de gaulle 50 ans après sa
démission vole pas eu sur lefigaro.fr
nous dit très justement que la période
des les mentalités n'étaient pas les
mêmes
et nicole au moins lui il avait eu le
courage de partir même si le non au
référendum ne remettait pas en cause sa
politique
et puis brownie tôt ajoute ce qui est
vrai de gaulle l'avait une légitimité
qu'aucun politique français actuel n'a
évidemment c'était avec sa place dans
l'histoire ça change
coup la donne et r34 ce n'est pas aux et
de regretter de gaulle ont été français
avant tout et de gaulle avait pour
obsession l'intérêt de la france est
bien un dernier sujet du spécial
guillaume bernard plus si vous en parlez
d'un régime monarchique impérial même
celui du japon akihito est le 125e
empereur du japon vous rendez compte
125e empereur de la dynastie va
appliquer la semaine prochaine
c'est une ovation oui c'est l'un des ses
l'un des premiers à appliquer c'est
l'occasion pour le figaro magazine de
parler de ce pays
alors je vous la fais très courte parce
que parce que le dossier fait une
dizaine de pages mais en fait ils sont
c'est presque un autre monde au japon
voici 3 3 petit exemple les prisons
japonaises elles sont vides à 60% parce
que le la pression sur la délinquance on
l'a peut-être vu avec l'affairé goldman
aurait tellement forte que ben voilà une
des conséquences un autre chiffre
il ya 2 % d'immigrés au japon le il ya
eu l'année dernière en 2010 cette part
dont 20 asile accordé contre 26 mille en
france
et puis ce troisième chiffres au japon
il n'y a que 2 3 % des naissances qui se
font hors mariage contre 60% en france
je vous renvoie au dossier de régis
arnould notre correspondant au japon
alors ce pays très différents est ce que
est ce que c'est un exemple est ce que
ça vous fait peur nicole schmid cette
société très verrouillé pour nous à
poney nicole lucide mais pardon je
voulais juste dire une chose c'est qu'il
ya très peu de naissances au japon
contrairement à la france
ah oui la tour commença donc il ya peut
être un petit truc là dessus ensuite moi
je pense que le japon est un pays assez
magnifique culturellement
j'adore murakami kafka sur le rivage et
c'est donc il ya une culture une
civilisation japonaise passionnante et
d'ailleurs beaucoup de français s'y
intéresse il ya beaucoup de français qui
partent en voyage au japon il ya une
montée du tourisme qui était très forte
après il ya la question de est ce que
nous pourrions y vivre qui est un point
différent avec vous savez une sorte de
de paralyser de momification en fait de
la vie politique au japon depuis 30 ans
avec shinzo abe qui au fond un parti
conservateur qui est une sorte de en
marche mais en marche beaucoup plus
dures qui englobe l'ensemble en fait des
champs politique qui essaie
désespérément de sortir le japon de la
la déflation donc il ya une situation
qui n'est pas si simple et en même temps
il ya ses rituels ses cérémonial ce
sentiment d'être dans un dans un monde
très différent du nôtre mais qui nous
fascine
il ya aussi au fond de la créativité
culturelle vient la question du moment
de gars par exemple est quelque chose
d'essentiel et l'ayant il ya des des
mangaka français donc moi je suis
partagé et j'ai pas envie de dire je
n'aime pas le japon mais je pense que en
tant que femme émancipée je préfère
vivre en france je crois que la
situation des femmes émancipées au japon
est infiniment plus difficile que
qu'elle ne l'est ici il ya un sujet sur
le droit à l'avortement donc la société
japonaise au conservatisme fait peur et
les caractéristiques quatrième à tous et
que les deux sociétés très très très
fermé sait on est à mille lieues du
multiculturalisme qui est en vogue en
occident c'est clair disons que en fait
on pompe
moi ça me fait ni peur ni envie parce
que c'est une société qui est
incomparable avec celle de la france
parce que en termes culturels
moi je me rappelle juste petite anecdote
j'étais allé au japon et dans le métro
con
le métro est bondé il n'y a pas un bruit
est une personne qui parle parce que
c'est trop impoli de parler donc c'est
assez dur à imaginer il ya évidemment
comparaison entre l'ambiance dans le tgv
français est dans les huits voilà c'est
ça non mais en fait c'est fascinant
parce qu'ils sont tellement différents
alors juste sur le droit d'asile
heureusement que tous les pays ne font
pas comme le japon